President Trump has got a new primary
challenge from the right in the form of
joe walsh some complacent conservatives
are laughing this off but i don't think
they should be so comfortable because
life has been good to walsh so far we
will examine trump's real big challenge
then the trade war heats up and Jimmy
John's the sandwich shop gets into
trouble for shooting an elephant we will
analyze the hubbub all that more I'm
Michael Knowles and this is the Michael
Knowles show
[Music]
Joe Walsh has announced that he will run
against President Trump in 2020 let's
take a look at his big campaign
announcement Walsh reportedly went on to
boast quote I live in hotels tear out
the walls
I have accountants pay for it all they
say I'm crazy but I have a good time I'm
just looking for clues at the scene of
the crime
life's been good to me so far at I'm
sorry I'm just I'm sorry I'm just
receiving word now president Trump is
not being challenged by former Eagles
guitarist and Rock & Roll Hall of Famer
Joe Walsh he's actually being challenged
by a squishy one-term congressman I'm
very sorry for the confusion here is
former congressman joe walsh announcing
his republican primary campaign for
president and Joe Walsh joins us now
good morning HR it's good to be with you
have you reached a decision yes and it's
great to be with you I'm gonna run for
president and and I'm happy to be on
your show announcing my candidacy George
no surprise we've got a guy in the White
House who's unfit completely unfit to be
President and it stuns me that nobody
stepped up nobody in the Republican
Party stepped up because I'll tell you
what George everybody believes in the
Republican Party everybody believes that
he's unfit he lies every time he opens
his mouth you say that you say everybody
believes he's unfit but one of the
things the White House points to and the
president points to often is just about
every poll shows more than 80% support
for the president among Republicans they
don't have an alternative I'll tell you
what George and look I'm running because
he's unfit somebody needs to step up and
there needs to be an alternative the
country is sick of this guy's tantrum
he's he's a child again the litany he
lies every time he opens his mouth look
at what's happened this week he is the
President of the United States is
tweeting us into a recession
I can tell you George that most of my
former colleagues up on the hill they
agree privately with everything I'm
saying how do you explain why because
they're afraid insisted because they're
scared to death they're scared that's
why they're doing every Republican
believes that President Trump is unfit
for office he said well I'm a Republican
and I don't think he's unfit for office
and I suspect many of you were
Republicans and I suspect many of you
don't think he's unfit for office and
actually he's got really really really
high approval ratings among Republicans
but at least Joe Walsh doesn't think
that he is fit for office he also goes
on I mean this this is the issue what's
the alternative because he goes on he
says President Trump is having a temper
tantrums he's behaving like a child he's
a little crazy child he's you are doing
what you were accusing president Trump
of doing when you say he's behaving like
a child he's calling people names that
little child that little temper tantrum
you are calling him names
you are speaking without any pointing to
evidence without citing any facts you're
just name-calling and actually in the
case of his first opening salvo the
statement he's making I am running for
president because that statement is a
lie you said I am running for president
because everybody in the Republican
Party opposes Donald Trump that's an
obvious lie it's demonstrably untrue
first of all the Republicans nominated
him for president then they elected him
president now all of the polls show he
has actually very strong support among
Republicans so if you're running because
you think he's a liar
why would I vote for you you are
obviously a liar as well that's your
opening call a Joe Biden fell into this
same trap Joe Biden when he launched his
presidential campaign the first line of
his campaign was about how President
Trump called neo-nazis good people in
charlottesville and Joe Biden is gonna
restore character and integrity because
he's not gonna lie to you and he's not
going to be a vicious bigot such as that
what character your first line to the
American people is a lie what is the
alternative when we look at this guy Joe
Walsh frankly I would rather the Eagles
guitarist be the nominee
rather than this one-term congressman
when you look at him you have to ask why
would any
I believe that this guy is better suited
to be president than Donald Trump
I'm not saying Trump is the greatest
president in the history of the world
I'm not saying he's the be-all and
end-all I'm just asking why is this guy
any better there's another Republican
running against Trump it's an so-called
Republican he's not a real Republican
bill weld former governor of
Massachusetts even if you don't like
Trump even if you think he's a bad
president why would anybody believe that
bill weld is a better candidate or joe
walsh is a better candidate by what by
what measure can we say this is a better
option than president Trump I mean there
are at least three categories I think
and on every one Trump beats the other
guys we'll get to that in a second but
first I've got to thank our friends over
at wise foods listen I'm not a very
responsible guy okay I don't turn my
script in until the very last moment I
am furiously writing my show up until
the cameras go on okay I barely get any
sleep I go out every night on school
nights
I just I'm irresponsible except I can
have peace of mind because of wise foods
wise company takes an innovative
approach in providing dependable simple
affordable freeze-dried food for
emergency preparedness and outdoor use
because at least on the extremes I want
to be responsible I live in Southern
California we have earthquakes here I
think every seven seconds and so you
want to be prepared for when the big one
hits when government resources are
strained it can be days if not weeks
before you can get to fresh food and
water you cannot rely on someone else
you can't rely on the government you
have to rely on yourself and if you're
like me you probably wouldn't take much
care for yourself in these situations
but you've got to protect your most
valuable resource which is your family
my wife sweet little ELISA is going to
be very very angry if the big one hits
and we are not prepared you can't know
what tomorrow may bring but you can have
peace of mind knowing that you will be
ready for it don't put yourself in a
situation where you need something that
you don't have get prepared today you'll
just you get it and you put it out of
mind it's that simple of all the things
you got hanging over your head all the
things you're putting off and
procrastinating get prepared today put
it to the side you'll have to think
about it again
this week my listeners can get any wise
emergency or outdoor food product at an
extra 25 percent off the lowest marked
price at Weis food storage calm when you
enter Noel's canna wles at checkout or
by calling eight five five four five
three two nine four five plus shipping
is free wise has a 90 day no questions
asked return policy so yeah I guess if
the big one hits in ninety days and you
don't need it you can return it but
you're not gonna want to return there's
no risk in taking the initiative to get
yourself and your family more prepared
today do it is peace of mind and it's
peace of mind and incredibly good value
with really good supplies wise food
storage calm promo code Knowles Canada
wles get any wise emergency or outdoor
food at an extra 25 percent off and free
shipping go do it all of these guys who
say that Trump is unprecedented he's the
worst by what measure by what measure
are we talking about that you know if
you look at the economy president
Trump's been been president for what two
and a half years now the economy has
been great the economy has been much
better than the previous eight years
what is Joe Walsh's record on the
economy
why am I supposed to believe that we've
currently got a president who's had a
lot of economic growth in two and a half
years he's a billionaire
he's built many successful businesses
he's been in the public eye for 40 years
as a successful businessman why am I
supposed to think that a one-term
congressman is somehow this economic
genius and the billionaire who turned
the economy around is a dolt
why am I supposed to believe that Joe
Walsh doesn't really have any record to
compare this to he ran for Illinois
State House of Representatives twice and
lost and then he was congressman for two
years but at least while he was a
congressman not that Congress has a big
say over the economy the economy was
terrible
why else are we supposed to believe
Walsh or weld or anybody else is
supposed to be better than Trump is it
because of these supposedly crazy things
that Donald Trump says he does say crazy
things he says funny things the other
day he was talking about a trade war
with China and he he said I
to fight this trade war with China then
he looked up to heaven and he said I am
the chosen one I am the one who's going
to take on China he was joking he was
kind of laughing at the time the
reporters were laughing he talked about
how he was joking afterwards he makes
jokes I mean he said TV stories made
jokes his whole life he'll use the
phrase very stable genius he'll tweet
about Kofi right this is a guy who tells
jokes pretty clear Joe Walsh has also
said plenty of crazy things when he's
not joking here is Joe Walsh giving an
endorsement on film of giving
four-year-olds mortar and grenade
training after he got duped by Sacha
Baron Cohen the intensive three week
kindergarten course introduces specially
selected children from 12 to 4 years old
to pistols rifles semi-automatics and a
rudimentary knowledge of mortars in less
than a month less than a month a first
grader can become a first Grenadier in
less than a month a first grader can
become a first Grenadier and he's not
even joking he's reading an obvious
comedy script that Sacha Baron Cohen
wrote for his Showtime show who is
America and Joe Walsh so thick he
doesn't even realize that he's reading a
comedy script so if you're doing about
the crazy things he says I I don't think
this guy's a better choice than Trump
it's hard to find someone who said
crazier things and Donald Trump and
somehow the one guy who you know bill
kristol is now supporting or retweeting
the one guy that anti Trump errs are
supporting for president has said
crazier things than Donald Trump well
then what is it is it the tweets is that
why we're supposed to vote for some guy
over Trump because Trump sends crazier
tweets here or to joe walsh has a much
more incendiary record than president
trumpet and george stephanopolous in
this interview called him out for it you
said you want to make the case against
the president the case the question is
are you the best messenger said you want
to make a moral case against the
president here's what the Washington
Examiner conservative newspaper said in
response to your can potentially and see
this week there's the matter of his
history of being Trumper than Trump he's
made a living on pedaling the same sort
of demagoguery conspiracy mongering and
right-wing bomb throwing for which he
now condemns the president he responds I
helped to create Trump and George that's
not an easy thing to say I look we were
divided before Trump I went to
Washington eight years ago the part of
the Tea Party class wanted to shake
Washington up I got involved in the
battles and there were plenty of times
where I went beyond the policy and the
idea differences and I got personal and
I got hateful you did provide aiding
comfort for the kinds of things he was
saying you mentioned Obama you called
President Obama Muslim an enemy a
traitor and you often spoke out on
racial themes want to show a couple of
tweets that you had right there number
one we lowered the bar for Obama he was
held to a lower lower standard because
he was black that was just in 2017 and
then a few months after that not just
President Obama senator Kamala Harris
said something really dumb men if you're
black and a woman you can say dumb
things lowered the bar that is kind of
textbook racism and sexism well
again well uh never mind I'm sorry so
even when you're talking about Twitter
this guy has said more incendiary things
and I don't just mean to call out Joe
Walsh who cares about Joe Walsh Joe
Walsh is going nowhere I'm saying it
because in a way everyone challenging
Trump is a sort of Joe Walsh everyone
challenging Trump has their own Twitter
history has said stupid things on camera
has a weird personal life all of them is
it the character I mean just look at
character right if you just look at
their personal lives Trump always gets
knocked for his personal lives because
he's been married multiple times and
he's been divorced and all of that well
here to Joe Walsh Joe Walsh who is a
stand-in for the Trump opponents joe
walsh probably doesn't want to throw
many stones he's divorced he's remarried
his wife sued him because he didn't pay
child support he then filed a motion
with a judge to try to stop paying child
support because he was unemployed that
that is the guy you say I have this
Trump as a terrible character and I have
sterling character even though I've done
exactly the same things I've said the
same things I've tweeted the same things
and I helped create
Trump therefore vote for me because
Trump is bad
and it's not just joe walsh we all
created Donald Trump Trump is us Trump
is America
PJ O'Rourke the conservative satirist
when Trump was running he had a great
article I'm gonna paraphrase the
headline because I don't quite remember
it but was something to the effective of
ugly hair garish tastes Donald Trump is
America he is and in a representative
government in a republic such as ours
the guy who's in office reflects the
country he is us look we a lot of people
in this country get divorced and
remarried a lot of people in this
country say a lot of things on the
internet a lot of people in this country
make jokes a lot of people in this
country are egotistical that's he is us
right he is us and he is certainly joe
walsh walsh is trying to spin the
revelation of of all of these things
about himself
as courage this is he says this is why
other people won't run against President
Trump there is a kind of courage
involved here that's not the kind of
wall she's talking about we'll get to
that in a second but first I've got to
thank our friends over at Express VPN
you probably can't trust certain
elements in Silicon Valley if you know
what I mean to treat conservatives
fairly I'm not going to name out any
companies here but I think we all know
what we're talking about you're probably
watching this show on one of those
platforms right now unless the show gets
kicked off which it regularly does how
can you trust those companies to handle
your privacy and personal online data
this is why I recommend expressvpn every
time you go online big tech companies
can use your IP address to match your
internet activity to your identity for
your location if you are listening to
this show you probably tune into some
pretty weird stuff on the internet so
you probably don't want your browser
history being publicized for Altis all
those all those dark crazy websites like
a daily wire calm you just don't want it
you don't want it being publicized that
is why I love expressvpn
search engines and media sites cannot
see my IP address at all when I use
Express VPN my identity is masked and
it has the added benefit of encrypting
100% of your data to keep you safe from
people who you don't want to have your
data and I'm joking a little bit of
course but I'm deadly serious about
online privacy and data people don't
think about it that much because you're
you know you just go on the internet you
think Oh everything's free I just use
all these services for free
nothing's free ain't no such thing as a
free lunch the cost is your data and you
don't want your data in the wrong hands
seriously you can protect your data
today for a very very very low price
less than one or two cups of coffee a
month but you've got to do it you just
do it you flip it on and you don't think
about it again protect your online
activity today with the VPN that I trust
to keep my data safe expressvpn comm /
michael mi CH AE l claim an exclusive
offer for my listeners expr ESS VPN comm
/ michael mi CH AE l three months free
with a one-year package expressvpn comm
/ michael to get started here is how
Walsh Walsh at Walsh as himself and as
the stand in for all the anti-trump
forces tries to spin why his bad
character is good but trumps bad
character is bad and why he who's
accomplished basically nothing in his
life is gonna save the country and Trump
who's accomplished a lot in his life he
is gonna destroy the country here's his
spin look George this isn't easy to do I
just sat down with you and said I'm
gonna run for president I'm gonna
challenge this guy I'm opening up my
life to tweets and attacks everything
I've said in tweeted now Trump's gonna
go after and his bullies are gonna go
after you ready for it yes I'm ready for
it right there is courage involved in
running for office there actually is you
opened yourself up to all these attacks
but Trump has already demonstrated that
right it's kind of a wash it's easy to
preen from the sidelines but when you
actually compare yourself it's a little
bit tougher you might find out like Joe
Walsh you're not that much more virtuous
than Donald Trump you're not anywhere
near as impressive as Donald Trump you
might find out that the narrative the
Trump is the worst guy in the world is
maybe just that it might just be a
contrived narrative and and and Walsh is
not the only one who's doing this kind
of stuff Trump is also being challenged
hysterical terms from everyone from the
far right to the far left and the center
right in the center left here is Brett
Stevens speaking on Meet the Press in
even more hyperbolic terms than joe
walsh the real issue for for republicans
is simply to call out the fact that the
president does not stand in any way for
the traditional conservative economic
principles that have defined the party
for the better part of the last 70 years
so what he just said is not true it's a
misconception I'm not saying he's lying
but he's getting it wrong
Stevens is making this economic argument
that Donald Trump is totally reversing
conservative and Republican economic
policies of the last 70 years you hear
this a lot from libertarians Trump is
not a true conservative capital T
capital C trademark over the e because
he's questioning unfettered global free
trade is this really the test of a
conservative are you serious
it maybe it is the test of a
conservative but it's probably not in
the direction that Brett Stevens and the
libertarians want it to be in the
historical record is pretty clear the
GOP was founded as a protectionist party
it was founded in large part to oppose
unfettered global free trade Abraham
Lincoln the founding president of the
Republican Party said quote give me a
tariff I'll give you the best nation on
earth by the way I'm not making an
argument against free trade right now
I'm not making an argument for tariffs
I'm making an historical observation
that the GOP and conservatives generally
have not always been the party of
unfettered global free trade actually
they've only embraced that fairly
recently and for a short period of time
Russell Kirk who wrote the conservative
mind he identified free trade as one of
the great threats to conservatism
Russell Kirk's book is one of the
founding books of the modern
conservative movement America
what happened after World War two
because we were fighting a gold cold war
against Soviet Communism you had a lot
of conservatives embrace global trade
that was to win the Cold War that was to
draw a distinction with the command
economy of the Soviet Union but in
politics we don't just live as
abstracted brains floating in the sky
somewhere it's based on circumstances
when circumstances change then our
strategies and our tactics change too
sometimes our enemies change our
opponents change so you you had
basically from the 1980s and into the
90s you had the conservative orthodoxy
on global unfettered free trade and
that's pretty much when it ended I mean
you're looking at like maybe 20 years of
that opinion then pretty quickly you had
conservative sounding a warning cry on
global trade arrangements for the past
20 years why because while there has
been a lot of advantage to certain trade
arrangements there has been a big
disadvantage to many others and this
includes China which we'll get to in a
second because the trade war with China
is heating up there's a lot of
information going on about that so
unlike what Brett Stevens is saying
you're not talking about appending 70
years of conservative opinion on
economics and trade you're talking about
may be upsetting 15 or 20 years and by
the way Trump isn't even doing that I
think he still holds the general
conservative ideas lower taxes lower
regulation help out the economy economic
growth as a pillar of conservative
thought Trump has repeatedly said he
wants no tariffs he want zero tariffs so
he's not even appending what Brett
Stevens the same just totally untrue but
the arguments against Trump that are
going on right now on the left and the
right are not about facts they're about
insinuation right they'll say okay oh
I've seen the tape maybe he's not a
racist but secretly I think he is he
said that he hates racism he condemns it
repeatedly but secretly I think he maybe
he is a racist maybe Trump hasn't caused
World War three but secretly secretly
and my telepathic plane that I have with
President Trump secretly he wants to
maybe Trump isn't selling out
conservative principles maybe I'm
misrepresenting conservative history and
principles but secretly secretly though
he wants to and then you have breath
Stevens go for the jugular on the
hyperbole never mind the economic
principles broader principles of
character I mean what we saw over the
last few days is a president who is
either mentally unwell or morally unfit
maybe both I don't know but it's
important to simply call these things as
we
as we see them yeah you you have
behavior that is is unprecedented in any
kind of presidential history in the
United States or or or frankly elsewhere
unprecedented behavior immoral unfit you
notice he can't name any of the behavior
he just says it it's just insinuation
that's what the critics do he can't name
the behavior what behavior is
unprecedented that he says outrageous
things I think that's what it comes down
to
but he says outrageous things just a
quick trip down memory lane the Bush
administration criticized its opponents
for living in the quote reality based
community so that's an actual quote this
was a big moment in the Bush
administration because the critic said
hold on you guys are living in such a
fantasy land you're you're criticizing
us for living in the reality based
community the point they were trying to
make in the Bush administration was that
the u.s. actually has so much influence
that they can change the nature of
reality whether or not that was born out
is a matter for another time but it's a
pretty outrageous thing Ronald Reagan on
the radio one time declared the Soviet
Union illegal and said the bombs would
drop in five minutes
pretty pretty outrageous thing to say
Soviet Union went on high alert we
almost had nuclear war because of it
Lyndon Johnson said disgusting things
one one time more than one time he
whipped out little Lyndon Johnson in
cabinet meetings he held other meetings
on the John Kennedy John Kennedy pimped
out his interns to his staffers in the
White House swimming pool pretty
outrageous behavior whatever Trump is
doing I don't think it's unprecedented
don't forget what three presidents ago
not Obama not Bush but Clinton don't
forget what he was doing the Oval Office
unprecedented Brett Stevens I mean
hysterical no facts here just
insinuation and then we get on CNN on
reliable sources the most ironically
name TV show in television history you
get a psychiatrist named dr. Alan
Francis who has really just gone for it
he's done with all this mild-mannered
talk he's saying Trump is Hitler well I
think that medicalizing politics has
three very dire consequences hmm the
first is that it stigmatizes the
mentally ill I've known thousands of
patient
almost all of them have been
well-behaved well-mannered good people
Trump is none of these lumping the
mentally ill with Trump is a terrible
insult to the middlee land they have
enough problems in stigma as it is the
second issue is that calling Trump crazy
hides the fact that we're crazy for
having elected him and even crazier for
allowing his crazy policies to persist
Trump is as destructive a person in this
century as Hitler Stalin and Mao were in
the last century he may be responsible
for many more million deaths than they
were
he needs to be contained but he needs to
be contained by attacking his policies
not his person and there you have Ryan
Stelter looking really really serious
while he's making this crazy point
obviously the political point is making
is very stupid but the meta political
point that he's making the point about
how we talk about politics is actually a
good point and this is what it comes
down to this is this is what the big
challenge for Trump comes down to what
this psychiatrist this lunatic is saying
on TV is that we shouldn't just bring on
TV psychiatrists and have them diagnose
Trump with some medical condition based
on nothing which is dangerous and it
makes psychiatrists look like even more
of quacks than they already look like
and it undermines the purpose of
representative government where we
debate things in the public square
Francis is right on this point if people
want to take down Trump they should try
to do it by attacking what he's done not
by attacking his person or his psyche
this is president Trump's big challenge
he has to convince people his big
challenge isn't joe walsh his big
challenges and Brett Stevens his big
challenges in some TV psychiatrist his
big challenges he has to convince people
that he's the normal one and that his
opponents are the crazy ones he's got to
convince people that he gets America he
gets what America wants he's delivered
on a good number of his promises he's
got the right priorities he's turning
the country in the right direction and
what the media are gonna try to do in
the left generally is they're gonna try
to pretend that they're the normal ones
and he's the crazy one he's a bigot he's
a sociopath he's all of that that's how
they always defeat Republicans they
convince people that Republicans are
hateful and terrible
Trump breaks through that because he's a
celebrity now he's got to use that
celebrity to show that he's a very
stable genius as he said before that's
how you use chaos you know if the
narrative is that he's undisciplined
he's a reckless child he's impetuous
that's what some of the anti-trump right
and the left says he's got a show he's
stable he's normal his opponents are
crazy has done a good job and he's
getting a lot of help showing that from
Democrats he's got to keep up that
challenge be the very stable genius and
forget about all these nothings all
these little footnotes on history
they're not even footnotes on history
he's getting a lot of help from
Democrats like Joe Biden who's showing
that he's the stable one he's getting a
lot of help from people leaking to the
press there was a report out that Trump
wants two new hurricanes I'll examine
what I think that's really about because
I think it's actually not a good idea
but it's a good idea to tell the press
that and then trade war with China
heating up and we got to get to Jimmy
John's there's a lot more to get to but
you've got to go to daily wire calm tune
in tomorrow 7 p.m. Eastern 4 p.m.
Pacific for our latest episode of the
conversation do you know who it's gonna
have on it not Ben not drew not Walsh
just me little old me I will be
answering your questions live on air my
answers are sure to dazzle you then at
least dazzle me I don't know if they'll
dazzle you tune in the episode is free
to watch on Facebook and YouTube only
subscribers can ask the questions
subscribe to daily wire get your
questions answered by me tomorrow
Tuesday August 27th at 7 p.m. Eastern 4
p.m. Pacific and join the conversation
head on over to daily wired.com we got a
whole lot more to get to
Trump's getting a lot of help showing
that he's the normal one from Democrats
including the leading Democrat of 2020
Joe Biden because Joe Biden is showing
that he's senile I don't mean that to
throw bombs I just mean the guy is
losing it here is Joe Biden over the
weekend in New Hampshire explaining of
course how happy he is to be in Vermont
I'm back I've been here a number of
times last time was I think all the way
back in 2014 but I'm in here before that
I love this place I love look what's not
to like about Vermont in terms of the
beauty of it and what a neat town but I
mean this is sort of a scenic beautiful
town the mayor's been a good guy and
everybody's been really friendly
I like Keene a lot he's not in Vermont
and Vermont is not a town it's a state
he somehow managed to screw up every
single thing he said in that statement
been here but a lot of times been to
Vermont been here how many times 303 300
Joe Joe times he's not looking great and
it's not just Joe Biden oh I don't just
want to pick on him it does tell you
something the front-runner of the
Democratic primary is losing his marbles
but it's not just him here's a DNC
Speaker William barber explaining how
socialism is endorsed by both the
Constitution and the Bible God kind of a
strange outfit on anyway that's already
got you a little bit on guard is there
right I'm not so sure about that
Reverend I mean is he a reverend
[Music]
and yes God healed the sick the Messiah
healed the sick I don't think he upended
the Roman healthcare system what on
earth he's just saying words that don't
seem to meet he says well it will the
Constitution is socialist because
socialism is good and the Constitution
says it should be good
so checkmate capitalists the Bible says
that it will rain on the just and the
unjust alike which is an observation
about the nature of reality that good
things happen to bad people and bad
things happen to good people
socialism ha gotcha gotcha
checkmate Christians checkmate
constitutionalists what on earth does
that mean he's he's not saying anything
other than socialism is moral and I mean
we we could debunk we could debunk hit
the Christian argument the
constitutional argument for a long time
because all of these people who I
suspect have never cracked so much as
this spine of a Bible once in their
lives when they talk about how Jesus was
a socialist they they never mentioned
the scene when Jesus rebukes his
apostles because they don't want him to
use expensive perfume on his body they
want him to sell the perfume and give
all the money to the poor and he says
the poor will always be with you but I
will not always be with you give me the
nice perfume they seem to forget that
scene they seem to forget the parable of
the talents which I refer to as the
parable of the hedge fund manager where
where the good master rewards the guy
who got a good return on his investment
and he casts the unprofitable servant
into outer darkness where there's
weeping in
of teeth you could go on and on and on
as for the Constitution it's
unbelievable obviously there's nothing
in the Constitution that would even
remotely suggest socialism so they just
have to go and they say in order to
promote the general welfare which is in
the preamble and they say see and I
think socialism promotes a general
welfare so there you go that mean that
kind of craziness turns people off that
turns people off and so I think
President Trump is having a decent time
showing that he's a normal one
he's got to keep that up and one way
he's doing it by the way speaking of
crazy stories is pretty counterintuitive
but I like it and nobody has given this
read on it as far as I can tell
President Trump is pushing back today on
reports that he wants to nuke hurricanes
this story came out on Sunday that Axios
reported the Trump wants to nuke
hurricanes here's the report quote Trump
said I got it I got it why don't we nuke
them according to one source who was
there they start forming off the coast
of Africa as they're moving across the
Atlantic we drop a bomb inside the eye
of the hurricane and it disrupts it why
can't we do that
the source added paraphrasing the
president's remarks and the source
allegedly said you could hear a gnat
fart in that meeting people were
astonished after the meeting ended we
thought what the f what do we do with
this the source told Axios and then
Trump dismissed these claims this
morning on Twitter he said quote the
story by Axios the president Trump he
refers to himself in the third person of
course the story the President Trump
wanted to blow up large hurricanes with
nuclear weapons prior to reaching the
shore is ridiculous I never said this
just more fake news so what's going on
did he say it maybe I'm not convinced he
didn't say it does he really want to
nuke hurricanes I don't think so he
benefits from pretending that he's crazy
and from people thinking he's crazy I
don't think we have any evidence that he
that the president would use a nuclear
weapon to stop a storm or ever use a
nuclear weapon but I think he may have
said it why I think he may have said it
to identify leaks because what would it
benefit Trump to say this especially if
he's not going to do it it would it
benefit him to say it because depending
on who's in the room he could make that
statement and then assume that it's so
outrageous that it would leak to the
press and then you can tell because
they're the source is being quoted here
so it's not just that it's on background
they're actually using
the direct quote from that it could help
to identify leaks the White House has
been incredibly leaky and the White
House has also gotten better and better
at governing itself it was so much chaos
early on it's it's brought there has
been more order brought to the White
House since those early days I wouldn't
be surprised if this a nuking the
hurricane story is actually has nothing
to do with her weather nothing to do
with nuclear weapons it's all about
identifying the leaks in the White House
which is very important as more and more
people from Trump's orbit turn on the
president now speaking of something that
actually matters we've got to get to
China this trade war has been so
misrepresented most people have no idea
what's going on part of that is because
trade negotiations are extremely boring
and they're extremely complicated and
all shallows are clear and if you think
that there is a simple answer to our
trade relationship with China you are
completely out of your mind that the
only wrong answer on trade is that it's
simple it's really really not simple
this trade relationship has been pretty
poisoned since 2001 when we stupidly let
China into the World Trade Organization
we had no leverage on it whatsoever it
was completely unlike our letting other
economies in you know South Korea or
Japan where we had military leverage
over them we were providing a lot of
their defense they were relatively small
economies we could manage their
relationship China not the case they had
over a billion people huge economy
obviously they don't rely on our
military protection from the beginning
this was a tough problem they've been
cheating from the beginning they've been
stealing our property illegally
subsidizing steel and aluminum stealing
our jobs by illegally devaluing their
currency so it's not just that it was
the natural flow of market forces that
took some of our manufacturing jobs away
to the tune of 3 million or more that's
not what happened we would have saved
millions of jobs had we stopped them
from illegally devaluing their currency
which is a which is violates the World
Trade Organization treaties and it's
something that we can't really fight
against because if we devalue their
currency the world would spin into
economic chaos because we are the
superpower we are the global reserve
currency
I'm not even scratching the surface on
how complicated this trade relationship
is I'm just telling you it's very
complicated and so when people say you
know drop the terror
that is just nonsense that is not an
adult way to handle this
so this trade wars been heating up it's
been tit for tat tit for tat China goes
hardcore in its negotiating position
people walk away from the table as
things are looking really bad president
Trump has to face reelection in 2020
then apparently allegedly the White
House call China rather called the White
House over the weekend and asked the
White House to get back to the
negotiating table
why because President Trump said rather
than backing down on the tariffs which
he also signaled he might do that he
would raise the existing duties on a
quarter on 250 billion dollars worth of
Chinese products to 30% from 25%
starting on October 1st he also said
that tariffs on another 300 billion
dollars of Chinese goods would take
effect on September 1st and they would
now be 15 percent instead of 10 percent
so he just at the moment when he it
seems like he's gonna back down because
it's hurting his own base it's gonna
hurt him in reelection he says nope I'm
going all the way baby I'm turning the
COFA Fay up to 11 guess what happened
the Chinese yuan fell to an 11 year low
against the dollar in China it looked
like the US was going to blink now it
looks like the US isn't gonna blink
China perhaps is blinking this is a huge
win for the United States it doesn't
solve the problem it's not even close to
solving the problem it just shows that
we're moving in the right direction and
the left is furious about that
here is the CNBC headline this is the
CNBC headline reporting on this this
latest turn Chinese newspaper editor
debunks Trump's trade war claims says
China didn't change its position oh okay
well if the Chinese newspaper editor
said what what newspaper was that by the
way could you okay let me see it huger
Shin is editor-in-chief of the Global
Times a tabloid under the People's Daily
which is the official newspaper of
communist China it's the official party
newspaper oh oh you're saying that the
Chinese government disagrees the Chinese
government doesn't want it to become
clear that the US has just won its
position on the trade war wow that's so
I wouldn't have expect
that thank you for reporting that CNBC
for carrying the Pravda of China and and
their their propaganda against the
United States it's ridiculous this is
good news I mean the I hate agreeing
with Chuck Schumer on anything the only
place I've probably ever agreed with the
guy two places on the Iran deal and on
this trade war with Chinese said not to
back down it requires a lot of political
courage for president Trump not to back
down on this issue but it's very
important that he doesn't I think if he
does blank if he does back down actually
it will hurt him in the 2020
presidential election because it will
show he's weak and he's weak on one of
the biggest issues facing our country
and one of the biggest issues he talked
about on the campaign trail the other
reason I think he shouldn't back down is
I think he's gonna win and I don't think
that that Americans are gonna vote based
on bean-counting I don't think that
we're gonna vote because GDP is a little
bit lower if we go into an all-out
recession we might have some trouble in
reelection but otherwise people want to
win they want to solve this problem they
want someone to fix it neither party has
done it for twenty years and they want
Americans to be respected American jobs
American manufacturing they want to make
America great again
this was Reagan's call in the 80s
actually to pursuing similar policies
this is Trump's call now I think it'll
work you got to stay strong he's done a
good job so far it's probably the
highlight of his administration even
though some nervous Nancy's on the right
and were clutching their pearls and who
are nervous that their stocks are gonna
tick down a few days out of the week are
saying that he should give up and let
China eat our lunch terrible idea
speaking of eating lunch I gotta close
today on Jimmy John's one of my favorite
sandwich shops huge fan of Jimmy John's
now I'm sort of even more a fan of Jimmy
John's because the founder of Jimmy
John's Jimmy John Lea toad I didn't know
his name was Jimmy John but that's great
I really liked that he was caught in a
photo
hunting and this is causing calls for a
major boycott on Jimmy John's one of the
great sandwich shops part of the
outrageous that he was hunting and
elephant people don't want you to hunt
elephants now this crops up every time
someone goes in hunts big-game the
hysterical left the environmentalists
left the backwards left throws a fit
about it they don't point out that
big-game hunting is actually serving the
purposes of conservation because it
costs tens of thousands if not a hundred
thousand dollars to buy the licenses to
kill these animals these animals are
usually not reproducing anymore in some
cases like when you're hunting
rhinoceros they're actually taking a
toll on the population because they're
not reproducing and they're they're
harming younger animals who could be
reproducing none of that is included
none of that is mentioned that the
conservation movement was was founded
out of a love of hunting none of that is
no it's just the emotional appeal how
awful it is to kill a beautiful elephant
I love elephants and that's terrible
it's good to hunt certain elephants it's
a good thing it's not even just an OK
thing it is a positive good because you
can protect other elephants we need to
we need to shoot the elephants so we can
protect the elephants we need to protect
the elephants so we can shoot the
elephants just to show you the moral
backwardness of this you have mark
hamill who Luke Skywalker tweeting out
thumbs up to a boycott of all Jimmy
John's restaurants with apologies for
posting the subsea photo
it's the obscene photo of the of the
owner of Jimmy John's with the elephant
a few months ago it came out that Mark
Hamill sent aggressive text messages and
notes to his son's girlfriend begging
her and pressuring her and intimidating
her to kill her child because Mark
Hamill's son knocked up the girl and
Mark Hamill insisted that the girl go to
an abortion clinic and murder her own
child his own grandchild that would be
good and he was saying how awful it
would be if she wouldn't do that this is
a grown man a millionaire actor
pressuring some poor girl to kill her
own child his own grandchild that's a
good thing but the idea of killing an
old elephant is unthinkable unspeakably
immoral this is the moral backwardness
of the left they hate people they love
Adam
they hate conscious beings they love
unconscious beings I love I had loved
elephants elephants are my favorite
animal it's the only animal I want to go
see at the zoo
I like appreciating the beauty of
elephants if an old elephant is gonna
die anyway no one here gets out alive
I'd much rather some hunter goes out and
kills him gives a lot of money to
conservation and cuts the thing's head
off and puts it on the wall and I get to
admire the beauty of the elephant head
I'd much rather do that I'd also much
rather protect human beings I think
that's a good thing to do too but we're
in a culture that is very confused I
can't even say it's just the fault of
materialism it's just the fault of
atheism it's just the fault of
environmentalism it's not because it
it's so confused it doesn't make sense
if if we're all just meat if we're all
just clumps and blobs of cells then it
doesn't matter if I kill the elephant
and it doesn't matter if I kill the baby
if we're if we all have souls if we're
all totally dignified and the mouse is
just as dignified and valuable and
creature and in the image of God as a
man is then we shouldn't kill either the
animal or the human obviously humans are
built to eat meat most people still eat
meat so I don't think that's the
argument people are making then there is
the traditional argument that man has
dominion over the sea and over the air
that man is a steward of his natural
environment that all the animals are
here for us to be stewards of that we
the animals are here for our pleasure
for our enjoyment and we don't want to
be cruel and we don't want to be Colet
nests and we don't want to ravage our
environment but we want to protect it
for us that's the traditional idea and
that's the only idea it seems that
everyone agrees we need to get rid of
and there they're pursuing just other
kind of incoherent versions of it's it's
just outrageous and the the outrage
comes up every single time maybe we
should instead of posting around the
photo of this lovely elephant which is
going to provide meat to people possibly
it's going to provide Beauty to people
when it's put up on a wall and it's
going to provide money to conservation
instead of sharing that as the image of
gross immorality maybe we should all
tweet at mark hamill send them a picture
of a little baby and say hmm maybe we
should boycott the mark hamill movies
maybe we should boycott the Star Wars
movies for a genuinely immoral
act compared to this this moral
confusion on the question of
environmentalism and beautiful animals
that's our show that's a big challenge
not just a big challenge for Trump it's
a challenge for all of us we are in a
representative government we are in a
republic the government reflects us we
are the government we are the people if
you want to make a change got to change
yourself if you want to make sense you
got to make sense yourself if you want
to recapture a culture that will make
America great again that starts with you
a big challenge not just for Trump but
for all of us that's our show
come back tomorrow in the meantime I'm
Michael Knowles this is the Michael
Knowles show see you then
the Michael Nolt show is produced by
Rebecca dobkins director Mike joiner
executive producer Jeremy boring our
senior producer is Jonathan hey
supervising producer Mathis Glover
technical producer Austin Stephens
editor
Dany D'Amico our audio mixer is Mike
Cora Mina hair and makeup by Jesuit
alvera production assistant Nick Sheehan
the Michael Nolt show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 19
hey everyone its Andrew Clavin host of
the Andrew Klavan show the left is
unhappy because conservatives are using
the same nasty techniques against them
that they always use against us sad
panda they can dish it out but they
can't take it so we'll mock them cruelly
on the Andrew Clavin show